[Music]
what what did you ask for for
Christmas oh um I'm asking this is a
legitimate question okay cuz Elena's
like what do you want and I sat on the
couch I went huh and I started going
through lists curious what you ask for
for Christmas my mom is my mom and Dad
are coming this weekend and they asked
me what I wanted for my birthday M so I
told them I wanted a
um a
griddle a gritty a griddle nice yeah I
just I just did this no I want a griddle
to make pancakes on oh nice yeah it like
what kind like you throw it on top of
the stove or it's like I think the
electric Standalone one oh I'm stupid I
just keep it at a certain the toothed
like the Press right you mean by griddle
no no it's you're thinking of a griddle
it's just an electric one that you plug
in instead stick it on the burners yeah
it's one of these [__]
great for pancakes I just want to start
making pancakes every Sunday you know oh
that's cool make that a thing I like
that tradition yeah yeah nice so anyways
pancakes griddle what's your makes sense
well all right
so like a you know just
a brainless
consumer I started searching gifts for
men cuz I'm like I don't know what the
[__] I don't even know what about yeah I
just I'm
content I have things and anything now
just feels like more stuff okay okay so
I'm like so you're searching gift guides
for yourself yeah I don't know what the
[__] Alena's like I want to get you a
gift I'm like what the hell do you I
don't know oh Swiss army knife babe yeah
oh so I started looking at tools GQ says
that's the third most common gift for
mes so I start going through the GQ list
um oh this is
good yeah this is a good guy that's
[__] good I'm I'm laughing because
it's all the same stuff it's underwear
cologne um socks
theun it you know the beard trimming
[__] beard it's like you know it's all
yeah hair facial grooming MH and and so
on and then then I go to this CNN list
and I'm [__] crying cuz it's all
it all seems like stuff to get him out
of the house oh and the Apple Air tag
okay every single mail list you know men
are so forgetful that's that's what they
you know men you know us guys we don't
[__] remember [__] it's all the
marketing but the CNN list had me crying
cuz it was like here's an Apple Air tag
go get lost somewhere okay cuz it was
all outdoor stuff Patagonia jacket that
tube that you can use to drink uh water
in the wild it's just an image of some
[__] badass guy on his stomach on a
rock just like yeah everything in that
list was get out of the house yeah yeah
so I go to but bring the Apple Air tag
so that yes we can find you can yeah we
can find your body still keep track of
where you're going yeah and then then I
start going through Tik Tok uh
recommendations by dudes and I'm
laughing even harder
because uh the in the top three comments
on every single gift guide for men some
very ation of huh no 911
GT3 that was just a consistent comment
like one guy's like I'm a simple guy I
just want a a 911 GT3 RS that's really
all I want yeah and I laugh because
obviously Alina's like is there anything
you want for Christmas and that was what
I said I was like I don't know
GT3 and then she's like come on I'm like
like a [__] Apple Air tag I guess
yeah yeah yeah give me an Apple Air tag
and a
drill what the [__] this looks like a
flashlight this looks like
holster how are you finding these I'm
just looking up weird gifts on
Amazon I would love this can we search
some gift guides okay what do we got
let's let's keep going go down go down
yeah North Face traction water resistant
slipper okay that's actually kind of
sick that's pretty fire robe a robe
okay
boring mint no boring yep a wireless
charger boring yep gloves [__] boring
sucks
sucks a coffee subscription
boring the every item so far this is for
girls yeah yeah yeah yeah there's no 911
GT3 on here there's no 911 GT3 all for
girls yeah a 992 911 GT3
RS oh is that a watch sucks
boring yeah that was another one watch
case holder this is the per or this is
the the only one so far that's been like
oh yeah okay crockpot cast iron perfect
pot I can see that I use my I use my
[__] uh what's the brand of ceramic
pot that everyone has they come in
different colors black yeah I use that
[__] so often I love it ding it given a
[__] like a alpha male red pill dude
a cookwar on Christmas yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I you got the [__]
name wrong on this
one is this for you to use for me
yeah see I like this
carbonator sparkling water
maker I'm a big sparkling water guy you
like bubbles in your neck I do I like to
burp and I like to fart okay all right
all right yeah you're right you're right
you're right right you're right my bad
my bad that is that is a gift for men
you're right y personal concrete
fireplace kit sounds like men are pretty
alone yeah this is sad perfect for
s'mores dude imagine making a s'more at
your desk by yourself while you try to
finish an engineering project bro if we
still work if we still work at your
startup 10 p.m. at night imagine we
still work for full screen holding a
stick with a [__] marshmallow imagine
we still work for full that would be us
for sure
hey look what the wife got me yeah just
to nobody there's nobody in the office
yeah well I guess I you want
one I guess I shouldn't have signed up
to redo all the engine X servers this
year Merry Christmas to me I
guess Yep this is the downside of devops
that's a lot of time
alone oh that voice I feel so bad for
that guy yeah devops guy yeah third
Christmas in a row I've been in the
office hey guys not not like I have
anyone to go home to anyways Merry
Christmas Eve to you all I just want to
let everyone know that the servers are
online and everything is green the
server load is
down I'm going to go ahead and wrap it
up at 4
today see you all Monday I will be on
call if anyone needs to page me for any
ISS
you I no family this year or
so hope you're all enjoying your
holidays at home
yep I'll be here in the office by choice
pinging it all in slack yeah dude read
these
messages dude read these messages Clint
Merry Christmas everyone I know you're
all probably hung over from your big
family party yesterday just want to let
everyone know in response to my message
last night server load is still low
application is running smooth you can
all
relax that's so
sad that so sad that's a dude who I I
picture him he's got too much [__] in
his house and he's eager to show it to
no one and he's got like a utility belt
yeah was [__] for like like computer
like keyboard duster oh
no here we go yeah this is this is me
when I want to cosplay as you
oh nice dude not
funny man I saw a picture of sick bit
man that [__] suck yeah that [__] is not
funny at all that actually quite
insulting that was actually a [__]
bad joke man yeah yeah that [__] sucked
ass
actually